hi everyone sal khan here from khan
academy welcome to our homeroom live
stream i'm very excited about our guest
today we have satya nadella ceo of
microsoft but before we jump into that
conversation i will give my standard
announcement a reminder uh that khan
academy is a not-for-profit organization
we can only exist through philanthropic
donations from folks like yourself so if
you're in a position to do so please
think about going to khan academy.org
donate i also want to give a special
thanks to several organizations that
have stepped out of the woodwork
especially when they saw that even
pre-covid we were running at a deficit
and then as kovit hit as you can imagine
khan academy's traffic has gone up
dramatically and so they've helped us
close that deficit although we still are
running a deficit but special thanks to
bank for america google.org novartis
fastly and att and the amgen foundation
and many other organizations that have
helped support khan academy over the
years but if you're in a position to do
so please think about making a donation
so with that out of the way i'm super
excited to introduce our guest
satya nadella a man who might not need
any introduction uh ceo of microsoft
satya thanks for joining us oh thank you
so much sal it's such a pleasure to be
with you
so there's a lot to talk about obviously
in the world we were talking we were
briefly talking about it before uh the
live stream got started i want to
encourage anyone who's watching over uh
youtube or facebook uh you can put your
questions in the message boards and we
have team members who are we're going to
surface uh the interesting questions uh
not to put any judgment on the things we
don't service well we'll surface as much
as we can
but but satya you know i i really just
want to start at a personal level and
then kind of spiral out from there
you know you're the ceo of microsoft one
of the most successful storied largest
tech companies firms in the world
did you imagine that this is where you
would end up being what did you think
you were going to do we have a lot of
young people watching what did you think
you were going to do when you were a
teenager in your early 20s
for sure i
didn't uh
imagine that this is where i would end
up sell
i mean i grew up
in india i grew up in the city of
hyderabad and delhi but you know almost
mostly in hyderabad
you know in in the 70s uh when i was
growing up hyderabad is not even what it
is today um
it was a place where it was a little
removed even from what was mainstream of
india it's before satellite television
uh before even a lot of the american pop
culture sort of showed up
where i was growing up
but i must say when i reflect back um
i somehow had the space and time to
explore i remember the summers i was
recently recounting this to my own
daughters i mean i read a lot of russian
authors i played a lot of cricket uh
those perhaps were more my passion
and then later on in fact i'm always say
that i'm somehow i'm a product of two
great american things somehow american
technology reached me where i was
growing up fell in love with the
computing in its early form
and then later on uh was able to come
here uh for education and then get a job
and it's the enlightened american
immigration policy that let me drive
live the american dream uh and so uh so
that's sort of how it all came about but
for clearly my first passions were more
i would say
cricket and cricket and maybe a little
bit of literature
maybe you thought you were going to be a
cricket cricketer we already have a ton
of questions coming in from youtube new
permetha and sais the iran john they're
asking ranjin they're asking a similar
question
what inspired you to seek your education
in in the u.s or what inspired you to
kind of seek opportunity in the u.s i
mean to me um
uh you know by the time i was in uh the
undergrad uh system in india and uh i
was doing i did electrical engineering
it was clear in my mind that uh in fact
i look back at it i got a renaissance
education for tech
what i mean by that is i started at the
very bottom of the tech stack right
which is you know at the transistor and
slowly stepped building up my level of
abstraction uh i was clear that i wanted
to come to the u.s do computer science
um and uh and you know hope to get you
know i was not clear whether i would get
to stay here uh but i clearly wanted to
work uh in the computing industry so
that's what led me to education and come
to graduate school and then do what i
subsequently did
and what's your sense you know fast
forward a little bit you enter into
industry and and obviously by you know
i've known you for many years we've had
conversations at various events you're
and i'm not saying this just you know
just to be nice to you you're an
incredibly humble approachable person
i always find you know these these
events i'm intimidated by a lot of folks
but i always gravitate to you because i
feel comfortable talking to you
what what do you think is about you know
what traits did you have or or or ways
of viewing the world that you think
allowed you
to be successful in in the ways that
that you have hmm
that's an
interesting question so
you know
it's always hard to be super objective
on yourself and what is sort of your
quote-unquote superpowers or what makes
you successful take in what are also uh
perhaps uh your shortcomings
uh the one thing that i do feel um
i have somehow innately is
uh that level of curiosity right i mean
here's the thing i don't remember ever
having a job at microsoft where i felt
like oh i needed to wait for my next job
to do my best work quite frankly when i
first joined in 92 i thought i had the
greatest job it might be the last job i
have but i loved it uh
and
and and so approaching even what you're
doing what is the everyday mundane with
that level of curiosity energy
uh that posture of learning
i think that's sort of perhaps a lot
more innate in me i'm not saying i'm
perfect by any measure
but i never was waiting like one of my
you know people ask me what advice do
you have i say like just one thing is
don't wait for your next job to do your
best work uh and that perhaps in the
long at least to me
for me has been a very helpful attribute
i want to double click on that because
there's a stereotype you have you know
if you watch movies or you just read
business literature that in order to
succeed in in in the corporate world not
just in america and the world that
there's a stereotype that you have to be
very competitive you have to kind of be
elbowing out other people you have to be
marketing yourself and you know i'm
saying this very genuinely you don't
seem to be that type of person and i
think i tend to be a pretty good read of
folks
i mean what do
is is that true in certain cases that
that those types of traits do help
people or or you know despite that
how did you
stick out what how did you notice that
you could have that contribution yeah
it's interesting i mean i i think i'm
not even i don't think um being dogmatic
about any one trait as the only trait to
success is probably the worst dogma you
can have
uh but i would say like i remember even
the interview process for the ceo
uh one of the directors i had a
conversation with them uh and uh he
asked me whether you know i really
wanted to be ceo i said only if you want
me to be ceo he said no that's not how
you answer if you want to be a ceo you
got to say i want this job
and then i remember going to steve
balmer later and telling him hey this is
what happened he says you know what
satya it's too late to change i'm glad
you answered the way you should answer
because that's who you are and so i it
worked for me sal i don't think uh i'll
claim again that this is the only thing
that matters uh but i it comes from if
your previous question it comes from a
level of confidence i have in myself
it's not that i don't have confidence
but it's not that i'm waiting for
someone and something else exogenous to
recognize it or be rewarded for it
that's not what is intrinsically
motivating to me
you know how did you
define
your success did you define it as hey i
want to become
a ceo of of microsoft and achieve
certain business targets or
or is it something you haven't thought a
lot about or have you defined it in
other ways i mean i must say even that
idea of what success looks like or what
am i aspiring to do has changed i mean
over the years
there was a period of time as you know i
said oh god i got to make it to my state
team to play cricket of course i failed
at that miserably uh then i set a
different goal and i said god i got to
be a good engineer and get a job you
know got there
so yeah i mean over the time then quite
frankly one of the bigger changes in my
life that happened was when my son zane
was born and you know he's uh got
cerebral palsy it was a major change in
our life for both my wife anu and me
he helped me redefine even what what was
i aspiring to do what is it like to be
able to see
life through his eyes recognize some of
the role i have as a father
also being
what what can i do given the positions i
was in for the broader disability
community
finding more meaning in that work using
microsoft as a platform to find that
meaning so to your point i've over the
years i would say if there's been
anything it's ability to build more
empathy for what's happening around me
with the people both in my family and at
work and in the communities and help
that sort of change even my aspirations
goals objectives
and i think that's what happens to all
of us uh it's just the life's
experiences that shape you uh and uh my
and our ability to let it shape us in
all the good ways is perhaps been very
defining for me
yeah one of the things that i've talked
about in in previous live streams and
and i'll say it because your name kind
of leads me there is that you know in
indian philosophy there's this notion of
of southwark work where you do work for
the sake of you do good work for the
sake of doing it versus rajasthic work
which is work because you think you're
going to get a positive outcome or out
of fear out of a negative outcome and
obviously your name satya
comes from the same root in sanskrit
meaning truthful truthful work and and i
think a lot of what you described
kind of epitomizes that
i am curious you know once you
got the the ceo job at microsoft on one
level i'm sure that was exhilarating i'm
sure on another level that was scary uh
you know from an outsider's point of
view microsoft had its sort of so to
speak heyday in the 90s and it maybe
seemed when you took the job that it was
past that that heyday
how did you think about it because
obviously when we now look at hindsight
after several years microsoft seems to
be in a bit of a renaissance
yeah i mean like i'm a consummate uh
insider cell um uh and so i've grown up
in this place i've been here now close
to 30 years and so
um
i you know what the thing for me you're
right absolutely the job was very
different but frankly even um just one
level removed which i was working for
steve at that time i thought i
understood the nature of the job but
quite frankly the multi-stakeholder
responsibility that one has to take when
you become ceo was very different and
the good news was i was at least
you know had that ability to quickly
learn on the job learn
also be i had an amazing team of men and
women who sort of came together rallied
around me uh i was clearly no bill gates
not steve balmer
and i was able to sort of uh you know
help uh take advantage of the amazing
people around me and uh scale
um but to your core uh piece i think
that the
microsoft
that i knew and i grew up in uh both had
many things we got right and some things
we got wrong and so i just simply patent
matched i said look let's go back to the
very creation of the company right when
bill and paul started microsoft they
said we're going to create technology so
that others can create more technology
right we built the basic interpreter for
the altair as the first product and i
said in 2014 when i became ceo it's more
relevant
to create technology so that others can
create technology a software so to speak
is empowering the world and so i said
okay let's go back and have that sense
of purpose let's not do things out of
envy but let's do things out of
what we naturally can do uniquely
contribute and then also have a culture
in fact i picked up
the cultural attribute which i felt was
important for microsoft your point about
in late eight nineties we were very
successful and from you know you know
ancient greece to modern silicon valley
there's only one challenge right which
is hubris uh that comes with success so
i said okay how do we get out of that
know it all mindset and become learn it
all so i picked up carol dweck's work
and said let's let's have our cultural
meme of uh growth mindset or confronting
one's fixed mindset each day and those
two pillars sell probably more than
anything else i mean of course you've
got to pick your strategies right
products right a lot of things you've
got to get right
but to me the two necessary conditions
for
any firm's long-term performance is why
do you exist can you answer that clearly
have that sense of purpose resonate on a
daily basis with the people
as well as the culture on how you go
about doing things
so the why and the how are sort of the
most important to be able to do the
right picking for the what
and as you go on that journey i mean now
in hindsight it sounds very elegant and
very very like yes focus on empowering
others and and becoming a learning
organization but you know given
microsoft's reach at the time and
obviously increasing reach since then
the complexity of what it does
were there moments where you kind of
woke up in the middle of the night and
said you know i'm not sure if i can do
this i'm not sure if i'm making the
right decisions
i mean
every day right i mean uh every day you
have moments of doubt and uh you also
have the moments about say um clarity
and energy and uh you know i sort of
think about leadership is all about that
right which is as leaders you innately
have to
go at it and create clarity when there
is all kinds of complexity and
uncertainty you have to create energy uh
as a leader to be able to rally people
around a particular sense of purpose and
a mission and a direction
and then solve what is an unsolvable
problem right i mean you have to remove
some constraints one sometimes we tie
ourselves in knots and say we can't move
uh you got to be able to let go of some
things uh and then boldly go uh to a new
place and then uh work out some of the
challenges that come with it i mean in
our case for example one of the bigger
changes we made was our business model
shift more than technology for most
companies uh sal i feel that the
fundamental economics of what you made
you successful are no longer as valid uh
is when you falter and so that was one
of the things uh that we had to sort of
overcome in pretty harsh ways uh but
it's sort of without it you'd sort of be
worse off and that i think is where uh
you know that also goes back to a little
bit of this multi-stakeholder side right
which is understanding what investors
want what employees want what customers
want and to be able to find the right
balance
no no i mean it's it you make it sound
simple but i can't even imagine it
doesn't
i operate at a much much smaller scale
than you do and and uh you you seem to
have a much much clearer clearer way of
of dealing with things you know just
fast forwarding to uh today or to the
recent situation we're in obviously with
the the pandemic around kovid
you know microsoft obviously as a leader
of an organization you've had to think
about how do you
lead the organization itself support the
people as you go through this transition
but microsoft also has a very big role
in this being a technology provider
empowering digital work i'm curious
how the transition has been for
microsoft as an organization and whether
this has kind of changed your
perspective on the nature of work
digital work remote work and and does it
does it lead to any new directions for
the for the organization strategy
yeah for sure i mean as you and i were
just talking even before getting on this
call
i i think uh this is just unprecedented
right we're running in some sense one of
the most large-scale experiments of
remote everything and we'll come out of
this with a lot of learning uh some
things that sort of we will leave behind
some things which will be real
structural change um
you know from a microsoft perspective it
started for me my first grounding myself
and the company on the safety of our own
employees so we were very early on we
said look we're going to follow our
public health guidance and in fact when
we sent people home whether it's in
silicon valley or in seattle we were a
little ahead of even the public height
public health guidance around
work from you know shelter in place and
so we sort of took that because we
wanted our employees to be safe
but then at the same time we realized
that we needed to be digital first
responders to all the first responders
out there whether it's in healthcare
whether it's in the critical public
infrastructure or education
and so it is amazing to see how
all of those people were able to also go
remote continue operations so at a high
level sal i think about this response
face recovery phase and the re-imagine
phase and they're all happening
simultaneously
uh interestingly enough digital tech is
that most malleable of resource we have
to help companies be more resilient
as well as technology that helps you
adapt to change if you're a retailer you
know even you're a small business
but you're a physical retailer you now
need to do curbside pickup right so you
need a little app for that or you need
to be able to do contactless shopping
you need some technology for that uh or
if you're in healthcare i mean we've
been talking about telemedicine for
decades guess what i don't think we're
ever going back
uh to outpatient consults which don't
have some form of an ai triage first and
then a tele uh you know telemedicine
session and then you show up at a
hospital which i think would be
fantastic for our healthcare costs
education of course so microsoft's
really helping organizations of all
sizes in all industries
really get through this crisis while
first sustaining economic activity but
more importantly re-imagining how they
can use some of these technologies to
reconfigure themselves for what are
going to be real secular changes
and we have a question here related to
that from youtube mo friday says what
are you and microsoft currently doing to
optimize the digital world in light of
covid and
so so maybe on that part of it i mean
just touching on what you already talked
about
how has work at microsoft changed have
you noticed a difference in productivity
because essentially you have a fully uh
distributed remote workforce now and
if not does that
lead to new directions for even how the
the microsoft itself is organized or
where people do their work no absolutely
in fact this is another place where
we're deep in the data and the social
science of it even i would say uh to
understand what's happening uh sal i
would say there are three
at least dimensions broadly to even talk
about productivity the first is
how are people collaborating to get work
done right i mean ultimately you know
individuals work in teams and it's a
question of how is work getting done how
are people collaborating um and you know
it's not just meetings right one thing
is to say well everybody's on a team's
call or what have you and you have
the ability to do lots of meetings
that's important but work happens before
meetings during meetings after meetings
so how do you have the full workflow the
full collaboration
so that's one aspect we're learning a
lot uh you see measured on collaboration
like in fact we even studied github uh
and the productivity of developers
absolutely as measured by pull requests
and pushes comments so you know code
review is huge so you could say at one
level we're maintaining large amounts of
productivity um a lot of meeting time
right we're also seeing that multimodal
like people chat people
collaborate collaborating documents also
collaborating during meetings that
connections like the number of meetings
short meetings uh have been on our eyes
because that's how they know
the substitute for those hallway
conversations and uh you know meetings
physically where you would have the site
conversations now all moved to digital
uh and so on so that's a little bit on
collaboration second thing is learning
after all if you say that a firm is
about people in the organization
continuously learning that's changing
right i mean think about i was just
talking to the intern class of microsoft
today uh we have you know whatever 5000
interns they're all remote for the first
time so i'm curious to see how are they
getting mentored how are they learning
how are they contributing even to the
learning of microsoft uh so that system
i think is going through massive change
right right now in order to onboard a
new employee to get new teams to work
together you need to be able to do that
upskilling reskilling learning in the
flow of work so massive change the other
one sellers first line work in knowledge
work a lot of times we talk about how
good not you know remote is for
knowledge work but except that a lot of
people who are going into the
manufacturing plants building those
respirators and uh you know the mass and
all of the equipment that we need uh so
for example that's a place where the
expertise is being bridged uh to the
front line as well using things like vr
or ar uh and techniques like that very
helpful uh in terms of just the
reskilling the last one to your point is
mental in the well-being uh even inside
of microsoft we're realizing that the
nine to five that's first of all was
never the case perhaps but it's much
more acute people have you know are
taking advantage the good news is people
are taking advantage of the flexibility
they work early in the morning maybe
later in night
then they have other responsibilities
and the work a group around them is also
accommodative of it but we're also
recognizing that video meetings do cost
fatigue in fact we did an eeg study
which says 30 minutes into your first
meeting because of the high levels of
concentration you have fatigue uh so
that's what what even led to the
innovation around this together mode in
teams which where instead of being all
in these postage stamp uh boxes if we
could be on a stage together like a
conference room or what have you it
changes uh the mental frame and the
fatigue so so those are the types of
things that we're looking at to say how
do we facilitate uh better
habits and nudges in the system even for
better habits uh better transitions uh
and less fatigue and better well-being
uh as well as learning as well as
collaboration
and there's so much in there and i i
am so so y'all looked at things like you
know the the productivity of of
engineers on things like github
so are is it roughly neutral is what you
saw or in fact i guess there's it could
be
yeah i mean it's a great question i mean
i i don't think we really have all the
definitive metrics so for example if you
measure it by task i think you could
even say for certain roles i mean it's
not a universal statement we may be even
more productive than we were
before because after all the
substitution of commute times there is
sort of more flexibility and that
flexibility leads to better productivity
and what have you one of the things that
we are also trying to do is what are the
long-term effects right so what you know
creation of new like one thing is are we
burning the backlog or are you creating
new uh on is it different by different
communities the open source community by
definition was well prepped because of
all the social capital uh that gets
built in open source is
fundamentally remote
whereas certain groups that worked
closely together are burning down their
social capital by going remote and now
they need to form new capital new
connections in order to do innovative
things so that's one of the things that
we're trying to study
that's fascinating we could we could
talk for hours just about that but i
want to make sure i have time to you
know get to the the broadest view
of uh the economy and the role of
technology in the economy because you
know it looks like when you just look at
things like the stock market versus the
real economy we're kind of in a tale of
two universes right now you look at you
know those of us who are fortunate to be
able to do remote work to be able to
work in technology it seems like you
know to some degree uh not that much has
changed in some cases it might have even
gotten better because of flexibility or
productivity
how where do you see all of this going
where do you know let's let's
extrapolate for a few for a few minutes
on you know is this a real trend people
have always talked about technology as
maybe being a it could be an equalizer
but it also could be a source of
inequality is kovit just accelerating
that no it's a great point i mean if you
look at it
even on the trend side cell
it's a complex situation right we have
obviously the health crisis and the
pandemic
we have the economic uh dislocation
uh that is getting uh you know created
primarily because of the pandemic um
and but it's going to bring about
structural change even post pandemic so
i.e its impacts are going to be long
lasting uh there is uh the uh societal
uh change right there is all of uh the
challenges of race and the general
issues in our society
there is the world order as we know of
it or globalization
which drove at least the capitalism uh
for 30 years uh is fundamentally getting
reconfigured so you put it all together
uh i think we have to sort of be mindful
of multiple things so there is a if
there is a silver lining i do believe we
have to get better at a as every
institut every person and every
institution in using say the
malleability of digital technology to
help us cope with this change but to
your point we also therefore have to
deal with some of the issues all right
which is one is it it's the whatever
happens next has to be more inclusive
right whether it's in education do we
have broadband connectivity do we have
con you know do we have the devices uh
are we helping small businesses and
large businesses is it across all
sectors it can't be just about sort of
high tech as a sector it has to be about
every part of the economy it has to be
about knowledge workers and first-line
workers so whatever comes out now has to
be much more inclusive because otherwise
we're going to have a 90 80 70 economy
that does nobody any good uh the second
thing is trust uh because the other
thing that's going to be massively uh
talked about is you know as technology
becomes so pervasive in our lives and
work what's the integrity of it right
you can talk about it as ai ethics you
can say privacy you can say security
internet safety all first-class issues
then the other aspect to me is all
around um you know are even the core
rights uh
and safety and you know take even human
rights i mean access access is one thing
and reskilling and upskilling is going
to be a massive issue so some of these
considerations uh and sustainability is
the other one so are going to be things
that we will have to make first class
into our discourse on saying as we come
out of all of these multiple challenges
will we be able to navigate to a better
place
by taking a different approach to
economic growth at a fundamental level
that's what i believe uh economic growth
is super important right there's no
there's no point saying that like let's
sacrifice economic growth because
without economic growth you can't solve
some of the other challenges
but what we do need to solve these other
challenges alongside economic growth
one last question a lot of young people
and there's a lot of questions along
this flavor you know this is your chance
to be kind of uncle uncle satya for a
second you know what advice would you
just to finish off on what advice would
you give would you have given to
yourself 30 years ago would you give to
a lot of the folks watching who are kind
of like yourself or maybe like yourself
30 years ago it's a great question i
mean i recently wrote a
father's day post um i lost my father
last year and he was a great influence
uh in my life uh and as i was reflecting
on his own life and how he lived it and
by somehow him living that life what did
he teach me uh the one thing that i
would say is you know how do you keep
that curiosity and thirst for learning
that intellectual honesty and not being
dogmatic or fall victim to doctrine and
thinking that used to be the one thing
he would always say
that's the you know i look back even in
my own life i think i've been shaped by
that i've benefited from that
so keep curiosity alive
no that's super valuable well thank you
so much satya you know i think i speak
for many folks which is you know as much
as impressive as your role in the world
is i think the way that you do your role
is as that much more impressive so uh
thank you so much for joining your
inspiration for a lot of folks no thank
you so much sal thanks for the
opportunity look forward to being
touched
so uh thank you everyone for joining
once again another conversation
obviously we i would have loved to speak
for hours there's so many dimensions to
some of the things that satya just
touched on uh but thank you so much for
joining uh we actually have a very
action-packed week coming up uh tomorrow
we're going to have hassan minaj
who is of course the creator of a
patriot act and then on thursday we're
going to have nicole hannah jones known
for a reporter who started the 1619
project 1619 the year that uh slavery
came to the new world came to the
americas so to speak so but it's a
perspective on the history of slavery so
we look forward to both of these guests
and having more really really
interesting conversations like the one
we just had so thank you so much for
joining
[Music]
you